all right so with news that Kevin feige
is resurrecting Wolverine get him off
that log that means Hugh Jackman is
coming back to Don the claws once again
in the upcoming Marvel Studios Deadpool
3 Wolverine and Deadpool
dude did do Disney World I I don't know
it's a working title right now but we
thought what better time now to visit
Logan and do a deep dive pointing out
all of the Easter eggs hidden details
comic callbacks amongst other things so
Logan opens with a disheveled Wolverine
in the back of a limo with some ombres
trying to steal his chromed out rims
instantly he is shot and the title Logan
appears on screen simply calling it
Logan and seeing this Unstoppable force
be put on his back within the first two
minutes metaphorically tells us this
ain't your daddy's X-Men movie now I'm
sure you know this already but Logan is
Loosely like Loosely like they took the
idea and threw the rest out because of
legal rights mumbo-jumbo based on the
Old Man Logan comic run in this comic
Logan is much older dealing with the
guilt and grief of being one of the last
surviving X-Men the reason so is because
he accidentally killed all of them yeah
to Taco Tuesday will never be the same
instead Mysterio tricked the old beast
making it look like the X mansion was
being attacked by a whole gaggle of
villains only for it to be revealed that
in fact the X-Men Heroes were the ones
that were being slaughtered this then
drove him on a solo grizzled road trip
storyline he also slowly losing his
powers because of the guilt Logan
features something similar here with
adamantium poisoning his healing powers
taking a bit longer than usual and one
of his claws just just does not perform
like it used to if you're an old man
Logan with performance issues then try
new Sia
but aside from those few moments and
these claws through Jaws moves Logan
performs a handful of times which is
featured in a couple of the Old Man
Logan panels This is where the source
material ends yeah Noah hillbilly hulks
in this live-action adaptations
him wearing a tux though is a nod to the
death of Wolverine part 2 comic issue
after the Skirmish we do see the story
takes place in Texas due to the vehicle
having of Texas license plate featuring
wer112 this is a reference to The
Uncanny X-Men issue 112. in this Magneto
essentially depowers all of the X-Men
regressing them back to children now how
does this mean anything in Logan well
follow me here I guess we can make the
connection with Logan's diminished
powers and also x23 is a cloned child of
Logan there you go Chumps in the
Chrysler limo we get a glimpse of
Logan's a chauffeur permit sporting the
name of James Howlett who the heck is oh
right this is Logan's real identity
before he took on the whole mean guy
animalistic Persona the James Howlett
name of course being a pun you know
Howell was first revealed in the
Wolverine origin number two back in
2001. it turns out this dude is Canadian
gross yeah I know but it was originally
from a rich Canadian family back in the
late 1800s which we see in the live
action 2009 X-Men Origins Wolverine yeah
not a great movie but hey it's a movie
Logan is seen at a funeral proceeding
waiting for a client and this is one of
many times that we continuously see him
drinking his pain away due to the
adamantium poisoning him but this is
actually Greenwood Cemetery referenced
many a time in the comics though it was
originally located in New York state for
Logan they kind of moved it a little bit
to Texas but this made appearances in
the Fantastic Four Deadpool Punisher but
with its first appearance being the new
Warriors back in 1999. one of the
headstones Sports the name Peters my
best guess is that this is a reference
to Evan Peter's character of quicksilver
featured in a handful of X-Men movies
later starting a massive Tick-Tock Trend
with this scene from X-Men apocalypse
again this is only speculation so if you
think you have a better reference send
your Peters to us we would love to see
them oh no no no no no no do not do that
do not actually send them to heavy
spoilers I'm sure he would love to see
your Peters
there's another gravestone featuring the
name Rogers referencing Steve Rogers AKA
America's ass anyway we see a mysterious
cyborg character get into the back seat
of Logan's Chrysler and this turns out
to be Boyd holbrook's character Donald
Pierce now Donald Pierce has several
connections via the comics like the
hellfire club no no he doesn't know
Eddie Munson the other hellfire club
with Kevin Bacon and is also the leader
of the reavers which we see later on the
reavers are a group of cybernetically
enhanced humans who hunt down and kill
mutants for Xander rice in this we see
various cybernetic appendages and guns
attached to their human bodies giving
off some heavy Final Fantasy Barrett
Vibes but in the comics these dudes get
weird with things first they start off
as kind of just your regular ass thieves
but morph into dudes with full-on robots
cybernetic legs and even this dude with
tank treading as legs kind of reminds me
of the little dog from Jet Force Gemini
I I would have loved to see this in live
action because that's kind of Kick-Ass
but they've had run-ins with the X-Men
but were ultimately defeated Pierce
mentions he found the men that Logan had
torn up at the beginning of the film
saying it had to have been a tiger or
Freddy Krueger Krueger of course being a
reference to the burnt up janitor with
knives as fingers that we've seen in The
Nightmare on Elm Street franchise and
the tiger Comet was supposed to be a nod
to a scene that actually didn't happen
featuring leave schreiber's saber tooth
making a return according to an
interview with collider Sabretooth was
supposed to be running a major Casino
really wealthy and he kind of you know
runs the town think of like Biff from
Back to the Future too but unfortunately
this never came to be Pierce makes just
a filthy a filthy joke
I heard you was in Phoenix Phoenix Jean
Gray Logan was in Phoenix hey yo even
though Logan does have a bit of an
adamantium dysfunction this scene also
features two very tiny tiny mistakes but
when Pierce leans into Logan and says I
know what you hide in there Amigo
Pierce's mouth doesn't actually move
during this dialogue and if you look
close enough you can see the camera
operator's reflection in Pierce's
sunglasses a handful of times during
this interaction the business card
Pierce tosses to Logan shows that he
works for Alkali transigen which we
later find out is trying to clone
mutants from the genetics of previous
mutants that we've seen in the X-Men
movies but Alkali in the name is a
reference to alkali Lake which was an
industrial complex featured in many of
the X-Men movies mainly where Wolverine
was experimented on during the weapon x
program and also the post-credits scene
of X-Men apocalypse this featured the
com complex and alluded to the Essex
Corp aka Mr Sinister so this kind of
tease evolved into transition and
brought about all of the genetics needed
to clone these mutants funny enough the
transgen Project's first goal was to
wipe out all of the mutants and suppress
the mutant Gene this is similar to what
the Worthington Labs was trying to do in
X-Men Last Stand so again like it's it's
all connected man but in the comics it's
similar to Logan and the DNA of x23 is
what they're really after to help clone
her healing powers and as a result of
her being cloned from him you know what
I'm saying Logan gets back to their
abandoned Foundry Hideout and it's him
Xavier and caliban laying low Stephen
Merchant's caliban is essentially a
glorified tracking dog able to smell the
X Gene and mutants and had been used and
abused by The Alkali transgen company
until realizing what they were actually
doing and he got got the heck out of
there the wrecked water tower that
Xavier is being quote held captive in is
the opposite of cerebro and what it's
supposed to do dampening Xavier's Powers
rather than amplifying them we can also
see a slight amount of hair growth on
Charles hinting that his powers are
fading as well with old age he is losing
his powers just like Logan is Xavier
spouts out a bunch of nonsensical
rambling and playing that he watches far
too much television these are the only
voices that he hears constantly but one
of the things that he mentions is
actually quite a bit of a Cheesy
backstory so Xavier goes off talking
about the Taco Bell quesa Lupa which was
actually a real Taco Bell item back in
2016. so why the random Taco Bell promo
director James Mangold revealed in a
Huffington Post interview stating that
he was offered the Taco Bell commercial
in the prep stage of the logo in script
he needed some nonsense for Xavier to
ramble on about and boom and just popped
in the script for the casalupa
commercial boom right in there so uh the
the more you know kids Logan mentions we
could both use some sleep when talking
with Xavier which could be a subtle
foreshadowing to their Fates by the end
of this film I would say it's because
the Run of these iconic characters is
also over but uh Patrick Stewart came
back for Multiverse of Madness and now
the old mouse and feige are digging up
Jackman for Deadpool 3. am I Really
Gonna defile this grave for money
of course I am
Xavier states he has seen a new Mutant
Logan saying there aren't any New
Mutants and I'm gonna say that this is a
nod to the New Mutants movie that came
and went and no one even really cared
about but obviously is a reference to
Laura and them searching for Wolverine
to take care of her Xavier mentions the
Statue of Liberty and Logan being a cage
fighter referencing events you know from
the first X-Men movie where we see Logan
fighting in yeah yeah a cage he's a he's
a cage fighter and the conclusion of the
film leading to the battle between all
of them at the Statue of Liberty and
Logan having a family at the end of the
film sure the Statue of Liberty line is
referencing this but Xavier is actually
referring to the motel Laura is staying
at which is the Liberty Motel featuring
a Statue of Liberty on its sign later
showing Logan visiting there there is a
katana hanging on the wall of The
Foundry which is rooted from some of the
comic book story lines but most most
notably the movie The Wolverine Yoshida
had given this to Logan in the opening
bits of that film and it looks like
Logan has held on to it since then Logan
takes a look at his dog tags back from
when he was fighting all of those years
ago and connects to events in previous
X-Men films specifically X-Men Origins
involving William Striker and The Alkali
Lake industrial complex mentioned
earlier they even have the same
identification numbers so good on you
for attention to detail however they
have Logan engraved rather than
Wolverine which was asked for back in
Origins caliban confronts Logan about
the adamantium bullet that he found in
his pocket of course adamantium being
the only medal to pierce his skull wait
wait what about what about vibranium
would that work never mind but this
bullet also showed up in X-Men Origins
Wolverine with Striker shooting Logan
scrambling his brain couldn't they just
shoot him in the eye socket I mean boom
dead but the bull it is almost like a
silver bullet to a werewolf being the
only thing that can kill the Beast Logan
visits Gabriella and Laura at the
Liberty Motel mentioned earlier of
course being a nod to the ending of the
2000's X-Men movie there is a quick look
at a newspaper clipping with the
transginn files further giving us clues
about The Disappearance of mutants
researchers are stumped thinking there
may be something in the water this also
ties in with the DJs talking on the
radio at the beginning of the film
reinforcing conspiracy theories towards
mutants however this is partially true
as we'll talk about later just just wait
but does have some real life footings as
well several recent events with water
pollution and whatnot but Aaron
Brockovich in the Pacific Gas event come
to mind for myself with the
contamination of groundwater a funny
little mistake can be seen at 28 minutes
and 46 seconds if you look at the
reflection in Pierce's glasses it's
always these glasses but you can see a
green screen glove that he's wearing on
his hand for the cybernetic hand visual
effects it's a split second but it is
right there in plain sight this is where
we're finally introduced to Laura AKA
x23 she's a cloned mutant from the
transginned labs which we get a bit
deeper into later in the video but her
character of x23 was actually first
introduced all the way back in the X-Men
evolution animated TV show are you
kidding me I'm I'm pretty sure I watched
this as a kid after school or on
Saturday WB kids anyway being a bit of a
newer X-Men character she was introduced
in season 3 episode 10 simply under the
name x23 she actually only had one other
episode of the show that she was in but
was quote created to make a wolverine
type character to connect to the younger
kids I say I say those Dawn youngsters
just do not do not appreciate a
middle-aged smoker in a yellow little
jumpsuit back in the oos I do not know
why I turned into Foghorn Leghorn right
there but at x23 was her code name and
later became the x-23 or rather Laura
Kinney we know now in the couple comic
issues but really fleshed out her
origins in the six-part miniseries x-23
Innocence Lost of which a decent portion
of her origin story Source material is
kind of feature to hear in the Logan
movie Laura being cloned from Logan's
DNA was a big part of this and obviously
her powers and Claws show this however
like Xavier mentions later in the film
female hunters tend to have a different
kind of physical makeup likening Laura
to a lioness because of her foot claw
instead of the three Claws and the
knuckles she only has two and instead a
wild wild west to Gym West foot blade
for defensive measures Xavier's
surprised look when it's revealed what
Laura's powers are almost has a split
second smirk in there showing us that
that Laura reminds him so much of when
he first met Logan and also has kind of
like this nostalgic hope feeling that
she could be the beginning of a new era
of mutants no no no not the New Mutants
get that out of here but this is one of
my favorite scenes because this little
girl is just going full on Berserker
mode on these mercenaries dicing them up
like a more agile Wolverine and moves
that are straight up Rey Mysterio Jr
wrestling inspired like a damn spider
monkey there is another funny
split-second editing blunder but exactly
at 39 minutes and 12 seconds Logan is
maneuvering the limo with Xavier in the
back seat but there is a quick glimpse
of Laura already in the back seat with
them however at this moment she's off
fighting the reavers Pierce sits down
with caliban to force him to track Logan
and the girl their interaction goes as I
read about you when I was a kid
I believe you're thinking of someone
else this is a cheeky line referencing
the caliban that showed up in 2016's
X-Men apocalypse being played by a
different actor so yeah they don't know
him and caliban isn't playing a Sly
Shaggy It Wasn't Me also the reavers use
sunlight to torture him into helping due
to his albinism and reduced melanin just
like the hit 1995 film powder didn't
think I'd reference that obscure 90s
film that somehow
burnt into my brain now when Logan and
Xavier watched the transgen hidden
undercover video Gabriella gave to them
there are a whole lot of small details
names and references to other mutants so
buckle up Bub sure let's get over the
fact that Gabriella somehow had enough
time to edit and organize this video in
a highlight reel but transigen is
actually using older mutant DNA to breed
New Mutants enough with the New Mutants
of these mutants we can see one that
might be a spin-off of Mystique because
of the eyes and scaly skin honestly it
could be towed as well one of the two a
white blonde hair dark-skinned child
that could be an offspring of storm I
only say this because of obviously the
look but also the voiceover from
Gabriella at this time mentions rain or
snow so it's pretty apparent Bobby who
is holding a static orb and we later
find out via the transition files was
created using DNA from Christopher
Bradley AKA bolt and Maverick the light
bulb dude from Wolverine Origins played
by Dominic Monahan Richter who appears
to be able to control rock and Earth
elements this is a reference to Julio
Esteban Richter who has Comic
connections to the New Mutants again an
X Factor
all night
no no it's a group called X Factor a I'm
not the one making these names dude but
he gets his powers from Avalanche a
villain that we briefly see in X3 The
Last Stand surprisingly enough this
bouncy ball Richter plays with is the
same one caliban finds earlier belonging
to Laura there's a child using
telekinetic Powers potentially from Jean
Gray and another using fire to burn a
guard potentially from Pyro from X2 or
maybe even Sunspot of the New Mutants as
we see some of the children escape the
facility heading off to the fabled Eden
in North Dakota in this video we also
see children being injected in what we
later discover is the mutant growth
hormone and this turns out to be what
Ajax was using in the first Deadpool
movie to create the mutant soldiers for
the highest bitters there's a shot of
Laura testing out her powers cutting
herself in healing which is ripped
directly from the Innocence Lost comic
panels funny enough some of the footage
that's actually shown in this Gabriella
you know undercover video was then or
later purposed in the New Mutants movie
yes in Danny's visions of experiments
being conducted on mutant children so a
future Easter egg in a sense because
that movie came out later at the gas
station Logan grabs a phone charger and
a couple of cigars of course a staple to
the old man and his love for Cubans well
the cigars I mean maybe the women too I
don't know I mean the dude in Days of
Future Past back at the hotel casino
Laura and Xavier are watching a western
movie on television which happens to be
1953's Shane director James Mangold
mentioned that the movie was actually a
huge influence when crafting the Logan
script basically a rough outline of this
movie showcases a retired Gunslinger who
just wants to settle down as a farmhand
only to be roped back into the action
one final time to stop a ruthless Cattle
Baron obviously Shane and Logan have
similarities in the fact that Logan just
wants it to hang it up hit the high seas
but then is roped in one last time to
deliver Laura to Eden Hugh Jackman in an
interview also added that pieces of
Unforgiven and the wrestler were taken
as influences too basically this old
retired Warrior giving it one last go
Logan flips through some of the
transginn files reinforcing some of the
source DNA used on the children mutants
mentioned earlier Dominic Petro's AKA
Avalanche of his Earth manipulation
Christopher Bradley and his Electro
Kinesis and finally Laura codename x23
with an adamantium implant procedure and
her Source DNA being confirmed to come
from James Howlett AKA Logan I think I
mentioned this earlier but Laura's
cloning from Logan's DNA was possible
because his weapon x DNA slash blood
sample was taken by the SX Corp during
the X-Men apocalypse post-credits scene
among movie that's absolutely
forgettable but the the reference is
there so thumbs up good job Logan flips
through an X-Men comic book making this
a meta in meta take but in this we can
see Logan sporting the iconic blue and
yellow jumpsuit spandex suit this is
again in the meta realm because we can
assume that him and the other X-Men
license their likeness rights to make a
little bit of extra cash on the side and
we've actually seen this done by a few
of the other heroes from Fantastic Four
to She-Hulk now this comic issue was
created solely for the movie with Hugh
Jackman persuading a couple of Marvel
comic Legends to create this for the
film most of the comic was drawn by Joe
caseda with the covers a lettering
coloring done by Dan panochen these
Comics are slightly based on real issues
but altered a little bit for the film
The Big two are Uncanny X-Men 117 and
one three two the first revolves around
Xavier explaining why he seeks to bridge
the gap between man and mutant and kind
and the other features a confrontation
between Logan and Donald Pierce so you
can see how these kind of connect to
certain elements of the plot of Logan on
the last page of the comic Logan
discovers the fabled mutant sanctuary of
Eden is actually a made-up place in this
comic issue with longitude and latitude
numbers listed on the map of its
location funny enough these numbers when
you do look them up it does give us a
location that's on the border of North
Dakota and Canada but far from the
mountainous terrain that we see in the
film no maces or wooded areas just
grassy planes and I would know because I
live in Iowa this is where a big shift
in things takes place with Xavier's
massive seizure we've seen this a couple
of times so far in the film but freezing
all of these people in place is
something featured in other X-Men films
specifically the post-credits scene of
the Wolverine back on the road the radio
station actually gives us a lot more of
the backstory of why Logan and Xavier
savior are some of the only remaining
mutants specifically X-Men comparing the
Oklahoma City Event to the Winchester
incident Winchester County New York
being where the X mansion was located
and the instant was said to have left
600 injured and took the lives of seven
mutants so one of Xavier's Atomic
seizures is the reason for the X team to
no longer be around potentially killing
any combination of seven mutants that
showed up in Days of Future Past but
this is another way they took the source
material of Old Man Logan and twisted it
to better fit the story instead of Logan
slaughtering the entire X-Mansion it was
Xavier in a freak accident there's more
of the road trip angle with Logan even
taking some inspiration from the first
Last of Us video game I don't know maybe
I'm just assuming this but Laura and
Logan riding in the truck has a striking
similarity to Ellie and Joel from that
game and both have plots with many
similarities of rescuing a young girl in
this kind of dystopian landscape after
helping out the horse wrangling Farmers
that is a terrible description but uh
yeah this is maybe the best scene of the
film or sequence of scenes where all of
them are having dinner together being a
makeshift family because even though
they are far from normal on the run this
dinner gives a perfect sense of normalcy
together as a family talking about the
good old days and it completely lets you
settle in and hope the best for the
group Patrick Stewart actually said in
an interview the most of the dialogue
between them was actually improv
revisiting the older X-Men films that
they had filmed together in this almost
a realistic quote family reunion for the
pair after dinner though there is a
mistake or maybe it's just a break from
the perfect family illusion because
Xavier calls Logan by his real name of
Logan rather than James how he was
introduced to the family no one seems to
care though so maybe it wasn't a mistake
and maybe maybe the x24 project teased
in Gabriella's video finally reveals
itself being a younger more rageful
version of the Logan we've seen said to
not have a soul feels like they finally
perfected the weapon x days of Logan
before he kind of created all of these
relationships in his life but x-24 is
also a nod to a cyborg robot named
Albert from the comics obviously robots
do not have souls sorry Spielberg's Ai
and Pierce had created a version of
Logan to kill the real Logan later being
revealed to just be a hunk of metal in a
fleshy suit this can also be chalked up
as Logan fighting his internal feelings
about being closed off you know being a
bit selfish going off of a few of the
Charles's last words you still have time
essentially Logan still has time to
change after all of these years and
years of his life that he's lived or if
you want a simple visual representation
good versus bad hence the white shirt
versus the dark shirt Logan stops off in
a forested area near a lake to bury
Charles's body after the whole x-24
debacle this is the best he could do
after promising Charles a boat and
living on the ocean earlier in the film
water and
after Logan passes out on the side of
the road and wakes up in the hospital
there are colored fish hanging above him
the coloring of the fish are yellow and
blue again referencing Wolverine's
classic costume from the Comics the
poster of the dummy pouring beer into
the brain also in the hospital can I
guess allude to Logan's heavy drinking
problems Laura mentioned some of the
other children she's supposed to meet at
Eden now most of these we've already
talked about mentioned along with their
comic book counterparts so Richter we're
on our way foreign
the license plate on the Ford vehicle
Laura stole is a reference to The
Uncanny X-Men issue 120 with a clever
nod on its cover chaos in Canada exactly
where they're headed foreshadowing
what's coming next Logan and Laura make
it to the quote Eden where all of the
escaped mutant children are hanging out
to nurse him back to health they use
small amounts of the green mutant growth
serum now later Logan takes all of this
and goes on a vicious Wolverine Rampage
and this kind of drug and effects are
similar to others that were featured in
the comics like Banshee which is a power
enhancing drug that was actually
originally created by Professor X
Richter can be seen in her talking to
someone on the radio a woman's voice
mentions that their Asylum is approved
and with them crossing over the Canadian
border this could be a member of the
alpha flight the Canadian mutant team
given this potentially more evidence if
you need this is in the credits one of
the can camera units is listed as Alpha
flight a a could be them a the reavers
chasing down the mutant children gives
us a better look at some of the other
powers that we haven't seen before and
the DNA or Source DNA for these Rugrats
the young girl with freeze breath coming
from Iceman's DNA who we've seen in live
action a couple times the girl who
features nature manipulation Powers I
let's call it that could have Source DNA
from nature girl and before you ask
there is no relation to the Nature Boy
Nature Boy
and of course we've already seen Bobby
and Richter's Powers there was a pretty
gruesome deleted scene featuring mind
control Power similar to the Puppeteer
who was a young inhuman from the comics
and later the child that grows grass all
over Pierce could have DNA from dryad
who has
clorakinesis powers they're just getting
weird with these now Xander rice finally
has a conversation with Logan and this
is where a lot of subtle background
material is brought into the open first
Zander rice mentions that his father
worked on the Weapon X Program meaning
that Logan more than likely met and
killed him in X-Men apocalypse the
weapon x scenes so there's that
connection but Zander rice continues by
saying that they essentially wiped out
the random x-gene mutations in Everyone
by the way of food and drink this all
ties in with the cane wood beverages
corn syrup and corn fields featured
throughout the story that's why will
Munson said that the corn tasted like it
was genetically altered to slowly cause
a mutant genocide through corn syrup
this explains Logan's more aged look and
why his powers are fading it's so
cleverly done because there are ads for
the Hypno energy drink throughout the
film the same one that Laura drinks at
the gas station and even a cane wood
commercial on the television at the bar
earlier in the film this is like some
they live subliminal marketing stuff
Laura though isn't affected by the
suppressant because she was created in a
lab rather than being a natural-born
mutant this explains the newspaper
article and conspiracies on the radio
from earlier as well another funny
editing mistake takes place when Logan
has had enough and shoots Xander rice
now Logan's right hand is the one that
takes the shot but in the next shot of
the film The Gun is actually in Logan's
extended left hand so uh the the more
you know kids Laura uses the adamantium
bullet and sure as heck does its job
against x24 but not before Logan is
skewered onto a tree stump now Logan's
death was actually hinted at back in
2013's The Wolverine from Yukio
you see you on your back there's blood
everywhere you're holding your own heart
in your hand and though it's not
identical to what she mentions it is
metaphorically close because the heart
in the hand is actually Laura his
daughter in a roundabout way holding his
hand as he dies in Logan's final moments
he whispers so this is what it feels
like which is a combination of two
different things one being Logan is
finally at death's doorstep he can sense
the end but also the love family the
feeling at the dinner table earlier and
what Charles said to him Laura and him
are family Laura and the other children
Barry Logan and have a makeshift funeral
for him Laura quotes the movie Shane
that was both on the television in the
hotel earlier and also was a huge
inspiration for the story of Logan
before heading off Bobby can be seen
holding a Wolverine action figure having
the same classic comic costume
unfortunately we never got the this in
live action which kind of makes me upset
but was teased in an alternate
post-credits scene from The Wolverine
you just know you know Deadpool 3 is
gonna throw that guy in that costume
Laura then takes the cross of Logan's
grave turning it to resemble an X of
course being a nod to the X in X-Men but
this scene took inspiration from a
couple of other sources one being 1976's
Clint Eastwood movie The Outlaw Josie
Wales which has a similar grave scene
and The Uncanny X-Men 251 which features
the reavers and Wolverine being
crucified on a giant X the final seconds
feel like the John Wayne movie The
Cowboys which has the main character
dying off and the group of children have
to figure it out themselves this group
of mutant children have to make the rest
of the journey across the border without
Wolverine without Logan anyway that is
our entire list of Easter eggs and
breakdown of Logan a ton of work was was
put into this from the whole team so let
us know if we missed anything big or
small like Logan's limp carrying over
from the Wolverine and I'm pretty sure
Donald Pierce says it's just a flesh
wound referencing Monty Python in the
Holy Grail at some point but I couldn't
find it so if you do I'll give you a
cookie a chump but yeah revisiting Logan
was great not sure if I've actually even
re-watched it all the way through since
his release and I'm really really
curious what they're gonna do with the
character in Deadpool 3. anyway I'd love
to hear your thoughts on Logan is this
one of the best superhero movies in the
last decade and do you want to see that
classic costume in live action and I'll
let you know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
Black Adam and Dawn of the Dead on the
15th of January and all you gotta do to
get a chance of winning this is like
this video subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment down below with
your thoughts on Logan we picked the
comments at random at the end of of the
month and the winners of last month are
on screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos Avatar fever is back baby after a
decade so get on that blue cat bandwagon
again but with that out of the way thank
you so much for your constant support
I've been Jared I'll see you in the next
one take care and peace